Wait, where
are we going?
Why, why, why?
I'm so sleepy!
Calm about!
Good morning, Vito and I'm booze like you!
Bloodborne Kart?
And Black Ops too.
Good morning, Vito.
Why are Nintendo directs always so early?
Bloodborne Kart would go insane numbers.
It would be huge.
Also, the music is so like...
I fall.
I'm just...
too calm right now.
I fall asleep.
For real.
Blame time zones.
Oh, Nintendo loves EU.
So true.
What time is it in Japan?
It's like yeah, it's 10.30 p.m.
That's not even so...
I guess they try to find a good...
Or rather a decent middle ground.
Where it's like...
It's like...
Not...
So late for Japan and not so early for other people.
Wow!
That'd be cool.
Thank you so much for the five good days.
Thank you for the 20 years.
My brain is not turned on yet.
Everybody isn't.
Is everybody else okay?
You bros winning for once 3.30 p.m.
But even that is not...
Or rather, is that not an inconvenient time if you're having
to work or something?
Hot dog Olympia!
Thank you so much for that tag gifted.
I'll try to stop yawning.
I have run out of green tea though, so I am drinking hot
water and, uh...
Yeah.
No, I'm from VR.
Why are so many gifts?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning, Minta.
What are you hoping from the direct today?
What I am hoping for?
from the direct today is in this in my essay I will explain
actually I kind of want Zelda I I fear that I didn't get it
like I don't have time yet to do like Tears of the Kingdom
and what was the first one what was the first one
breath of the wild thank you yeah yeah those games are like
I want to I still want to play them they're just so long you
know but
but um a Zelda another Zelda because last time we got what
was it like Zelda proper game Captain Toad 2 That'd be so
fun too.
Kamalachi Life 2 will be announced.
I believe.
As an F0 fan, my opium can only go so far.
Inconvenient time is the perfect reason to give to my boss.
Me and to his streaming.
I'm sorry I can't attend this meeting.
I'm sure they would understand.
Oh, Albraza!
Thank you so much for the fancy gift.
Thank you!
F0.
It is plain time, everybody.
I'm kind of like, what?
I mean, they can announce anything.
They could announce anything.
But, I don't know.
I have no idea.
I feel like we've been absolutely spoiled this past week.
Next Animal Crossing.
I don't know.
I don't know about...
I feel I feel a little like Not How do I say Less excited
about a new animal crossing Considering what happened with
The more recent one How it was sort of treated Everything
went to the mobile game And nothing went to the game itself
Rhythm Heaven News I was actually thinking about that i was
thinking about that i was thinking about that yeah i think
more time for another animal crossing unlike they did say
like no more updates right so i i can't imagine what they
would do unless it's like a spin-off game like the uh hotel
one that wasn't exactly my favorite i'm not all i i know
animal crossing is like about the design but i like just
kind of the the collection of critters i like fishing and i
like catching bugs and i especially like finding like rare
bugs and rare fish i'm that kind of oh chat's frozen thank
you new smash wasn't something hinted like that oh you know
what i actually really want and i'm gonna be honest i think
it's a hundred percent not a hundred percent i think it's
like possible that it happens I want a not 90% that's still
pretty high 50% elite B agents yeah I want a old snake
amiibo my my percentage kept going down it keeps getting
lower but I want an old snake amiibo because the master
collection 2 is probably going to come to switch as well
right but an old snake amiibo optimistic 30 it just keeps
going down and down
but i want you should play book no not to i've i've i've
watched uh i have not like watched a ton but i've watched
like corone playing and stuff thank you so much for the aqua
super Good morning, Mito!
I'm clocked in for this direct and literally...
Sincerely a Corvo slave!
Good luck with work!
Sunships, thank you so much for that.
I really appreciate it.
Good morning, Mito.
Good morning, Mito!
Oh, don't be nice.
Thank you.
Good morning.
But yeah.
Minto, you're thinking about this the wrong way.
The chances are always 50-50.
Either it happens or it doesn't.
Metal Gear Muffin, thank you so much for the 10 gets in.
Aizma, happy birthday!
Good morning!
Good morning, happy birthday!
Ace Attorney 7.
Yes!
Though I am behind on the series, so...
I would love for more Ace Attorney.
MGS game with Old Snake and Minky losing her mind reacting
to it is becoming a reality.
Old Snake mentioned.
It must happen now.
Oh.
It's high time for new Ace Attorney.
I agree.
I- I- I do- I do wonder like...
You know...
How do I say this?
Maybe with the Switch 2.
Gaming capabilities are a little higher.
But it's always kind of like one of those like...
How...
What game would they announce for?
You know what I mean?
Switch 2 has games?
I don't know actually.
I don't have a Switch 2.
Polcopia!
I think we could get an update on Polcopia.
I think that's likely.
I don't know anything about Pokopia besides what I've heard.
I feel like I'm so behind on some game series.
Get to watch the director of my Kamino Shima.
Jamie R.
X.
Happy birthday!
My birthday wishes for Old Snake Avivo to be real.
Thank you!
I do need to get a Switch 2 before the price goes up.
I was thinking that also I when yeah, I when I saw that I
was like There's no way that I mean there is a way but at
the same time Dang
it Waiting for an OLED release I might also I might just
wait.
I don't think there's enough incentive for me to get one yet
I am totally fine with my Switch as is I could use some more
space That's about it But for that I'll just get like a A
car A A
The card The card Why do I keep What did this say?
Micro USB SD card Yes Thank you
SD card Any interest in playing Mina the Hollower?
Oh, I've heard about it.
Wait, let me...
Hold on.
That's like the little mouse girl, right?
Mina the Hollower.
I've thought about it.
Because...
um it's like it's like old Zelda right that kind of vibe and
I saw my friend Maddie she has like a patreon where she
makes sticker sheets and stuff every month she's oh that's
raspberry if you've maybe seen her like resident evil comics
or Metal Gear comics.
But I think this month is Mina the Hollower.
And I was just like, oh.
Usually I find that my taste aligns with Maddie very much.
So if she likes it, then I think I would like it.
Maddie love.
Yeah!
I got to see her for like two seconds recently and I was
like, Maddie!
Maddie!
I've missed you!
It's Zelda Castlevania Bloodborne?
Bloodborne?
How?
Two whole seconds.
It really was, like, two seconds.
Oh, hello.
Thank you for the...
Red.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to...
Minto...
Nintendo Directive Watchalong!
I decided to start the stream a little bit earlier than
usual, because I think this might be my chance to only...
stream today, unfortunately.
I'm so sorry.
I'm like knees.
No, not even knees.
I'm neck deep in my move.
I moved this week.
And so I'm scrambling for all my packing to get finished.
So I think today, or I think this might be my only chance to
stream today.
Yeah, ears even.
I'm ears deep.
I'm deep, deep.
So, um...
yeah it's it's been it's been a little bit of a lot so what
was I gonna say did you take the spider dress nest made
dress down I did it's it's a it's officially off the wall
but I do have yeah a blue archive stream later today as well
I'll be on the Blue Archive channel.
That one's quite late, though.
I'm like total differences.
Very early stream and quite late stream.
Thank you guys so much for the gift and memberships, by the
way.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, no.
Thank you, Torgu.
Hope we get that Minto dating sim.
What?
Minto... What has been leaked?
What has been told?
If it's the cat ears deep, that's just submerged.
about this.
Okay, so don't have chance to tell you later, have fun with
RC and good luck pulling K and Otis.
Thank you!
Since it's Fest, doesn't that mean Rio is back?
Sorry, I'm now on Blue Archive Talk.
Because I still need Rio.
That's actually who I'm really hoping for.
Obviously K too.
I want K as well.
And Otis too.
I want them both.
But I really need Rio.
I need her the most.
Yeah, I like regular Rio, exactly.
Has leaked that you are the new VA for Toad.
I can't even do the bit right now.
I can't even commit to the bit right now.
I'm so tired.
I'm so...
Glasses on and everything.
I can't even do the Toad voice.
I'm so...
playing Blue Archive recently, I'm surprised how
beginner-friendly the game is.
It is!
Oh, my gosh.
They scared me.
Oh, I forgot that there was a Switch 2 version of this game.
I got jump-scared by an ad.
I forgot that there's, like, cameras and stuff.
I don't know why.
Including on Slumber Island.
Animal Crossing New Horizons, Nintendo Switch 2.
I'm gonna mute it.
I don't want to listen to ads for 10 minutes.
I want to talk.
Wait a second.
Hold on, not this one.
Every time I think of this song...
Every time I think of this song, I think of, like, this,
like, meme version of it.
But...
Whoa...
Yeah, the Joel Haver one.
Yeah.
And then there's Chunky.
Chunky is that.
If only there was a Vinto GamerSub's flavor to help wake you
up.
Don't forget to use Go Boomer, we're checking out!
Well, nerdy laundry.
Your dreams, maybe.
Coming true!
Oh, wait.
Oh, it looks so good.
I didn't ever play the original Star Fox because I did not
have Nintendo 64.
But, Mr. Toad.
I don't know.
I guess I would need a Switch 2 for that, huh?
No.
Sorry, I haven't muted just so we can keep talking for the
next 10 minutes.
rather than just listening to ads and then i got my vip
ticket i'm so happy to be seeing you on my first ever
concert oh my gosh jake thank you thank you for being a
treasure always praying for ghost discount on the switch too
you'd love bonanza thank i don't know about if i could get a
discount but thank you thank you thank you thank you thank
you starbucks has had more remakes than does original
entries starfox 64 was a remake it was a remake wait what
was it originally i don't i admittedly don't know so much
about starfox
snitch oh mr toad didn't want to go to the farm so we
decided to steal a plate instead i know some people are like
not so optimistic about wolf among us too but i am because i
feel like they wouldn't have announced like the remaster and
like we got like a full trailer and everything i think i
think it's finally happening i think it's i think it's time
i think it's time i'm
hopeful me too me too i can listen in the car wait refrain
from using the touchscreen while driving music while you're
driving while it's rainy okay that's that's romantic i kind
of love romanticizing things like that wait that's kind of
nice to actually peek i mean you could have done that anyway
if you just had the music and like was like oh it's raining
i'm gonna put on the rain animal crossing rainy music you
could have done that anyway but
But, now they planted the idea into a lot more people's
brains.
I hadn't thought about it.
It's just Apple CarPlay.
Oh, thank you, Denza, to Elexi's channel.
Speaking of Kinda Nice, it's Kinda Nice that the Skyline
Serenade Show at the Beacon Theater in New York City has its
general sale.
opening in seven minutes six minutes wow
if you oh wait I have a question Steiner hold on did you tag
me oh
wait hold on
hold on here listen to the ad listen to the ad already have
Super Mario Brothers Wonder on Nintendo Switch sounds too
much like an ad the upgrade pack three amoebo figures from
super mario brothers wonder are also available it's like add
voice and everything
because i got my choice samus wait for this
okay i'll mute it again i don't want old news i want the new
news give me the news At least the ad isn't pretending to be
something else.
Respect for the Odyssey.
Looking forward to driving to Penny's theme.
As well as your concert and NYC VIP.
Good, thank you, Nicholas.
Penny's theme.
I think I would drive around New York with the...
I don't remember how it goes.
What's that song?
The...
Pop Superstar!
sorry my brain is so oh man I was I was talking to Phoebe
and Vicky the other day and I was like hey have we decided
on this thing that we were going to be doing and Phoebe was
like yeah Minto you decided you chose it and I was like oh
yeah my brain and I keep thinking it's Wednesday but it's uh
but I I'm all over the place my brain is actually melted
from how much is going on in my head right now I drive
listening exclusively to life is beautiful excited to see
you in the girlies at skyline serenade this August yeah
thank you I wish I yeah I with the skyline serenade
announcement I feel kind of bad because I was just like oh
yeah it's happening guys And it's mainly because my brain is
so like, I'm like, I got to get this move done.
I got, I was like, I got to do this, this sponsor collab.
I got to get this move done.
I got to get this done.
Like I'm kind of in like a take one thing at a time at the
moment because I'm so if I, if I think of everything at
once, my brain might explode overload.
Yeah.
especially this week my brain is
you have that collab with doki tomorrow right yes doki and i
have a collab tomorrow uh we will be playing the new fears
to fathom game which is only multiplayer so i'm very
interested how it will go i don't think she's ever played a
fears to fathom either so what what the hell was that i
don't
What was that?
Oh my god.
I feel like there's so many events in Tomodachi life I
haven't seen yet.
So many events.
I haven't even gotten the Otage one.
I feel cheated.
Is that Cheela's dog?
Can't wait to see you in August and then we'll see you too.
Yeah!
I'll see you guys then.
Oh my gosh.
Steiner promised to take us to Broadway.
It'll be my first time.
I'm having trouble adjusting to my medicine.
What?
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to do that.
No!
Take care, Brandon.
I know new medicine is always a pain.
I feel better.
One minute.
One minute until direct.
Here, actually, I'm going to turn on the audio again.
Let me know how the sound is.
I don't have...
Oh my God.
Countdown, countdown!
Did you know pigeons are god-awful at making nests?
They are!
I didn't know!
It's because...
It's because they were domesticated and then thrown to the
wild and they don't know how to do anything.
They have lost the ability to bird.
It's so sad.
Anyway, Nintendo Direct.
What are we starting with?
He's taking you to Broadway to 4th.
Oh gosh.
New F0.
I'm hoping for all the F0 fans.
I think he's crossing for you too.
May our direct polls be blessed by John Nintendo.
Amen!
Hello everyone.
I'm Yoshiaki Koizumi.
I will be your guide for today's Nintendo Direct.
Nice to see you again.
Here's a game that's coming to the Nintendo Switch system.
Please, take a look at this.
My name is Lowell Miss Reads, and I'm known for my reading
aloud skills and more.
Rhythm Heaven?
I'm here today to help show you the Rhythm Heaven blue
screen.
Yeah!
It really is Rhythm Heaven!
There's just something...
It's so incredibly satisfying about Rhythm Heaven games.
Rhythm Heaven groove.
Like, it just needs, they don't need to change anything.
It just needs to be, it's like the same format forever.
It's the best.
Just get into the groove and press the correct button.
That's all there is to it.
But it's not always the same rhythm.
Listen carefully to the beat.
Find your flow and you'll be able to feel the rhythm.
Only if you have rhythm, I guess it's true.
Yeah.
Over 80 games.
The kingdom's everlasting peace rests on your shoulders.
you're awake go forth magician I can't lose and use the
magical power of rhythm to beat monsters cast a fire what's
that game um B a and a healing spell with B down a that
dungeon game like that that is also on the beat what spells
will it's a little different obviously than this yeah necro
dancer yeah yeah yeah And then for dancers.
It's time for the Who's Got Rhythm?
Quiz Show.
Quiz Show?
Plus, there are even more rhythm games in the lineup.
Enjoy all of this while playing solo.
And...
Or...
Dan, Emily, Leo, Sarah.
Oh my god!
Minto.
Up to four players can enjoy dedicated rhythm games.
Note the timing and block the arrows.
But...
I guess it's fine.
Or aim for three o'clock on the dot.
Dang, Emily.
There are over 30 cooperative and competitive games to play.
It has to be local, right?
That can't be online.
That would be insane.
Or with friends when...
Rhythm Heaven Groove hits the Nintendo Switch system July
2nd.
July!
The figures are available now on Nintendo eShop.
Oh!
That was Rhythm Heaven Groove for Nintendo Switch.
Next month!
You'll also be able to play it on the Nintendo Switch 2.
No way this is online.
That would be crazy.
That guy's back.
Just a little longer for its release.
Everyone chill until please take a look at this rolls up.
We'll introduce games coming to Nintendo Switch 2.
Yeah, everybody's chill until...
Including some games that will also be available on Nintendo
Switch.
It is like Warrior Wear.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a very similar vibe.
Master the way of the sword Let's see your best today
Onimusha, way of the sword A new entry in the sword play
action series Is slashing onto Nintendo Switch 2 Onimusha
Kyoto has been overrun by monsters Known as Genma Now
Miyamoto Musashi must prove himself If you have Switch 2
Yeah That might be the... where you get it?
Freaky monsters.
They are pretty cool though.
Cool design.
Master these techniques to strike down the enemies in your
path.
Only armaments are also at your disposal to turn the tides
of battle.
You can even use Joy-Con 2 motion controls to intuitively
slay Genma.
Wait, I love stuff like that.
I'm such a sucker for a gimmick.
Let me wield the sword!
I'm playing this devil right now!
Let's go!
I'm using tail controls!
One second.
I didn't have breakfast, so I'm gonna have a little snack.
Your unwritten epic begins.
One second.
I'm gonna grab some juice.
Dark Arisen is heading to Nintendo Switch 2.
I should have grabbed it earlier, but I only got hungry now.
You are the Arisen.
The hero burdened with the fate of slaying the dragon who
has taken your heart.
In this expanded version of Dragon's Dogma 2, explore the
new land of Norgon.
Seek out spoils, then appraise them to reveal new weapons,
armor, or skills.
With these arms at the ready, take down powerful monsters
and it makes me want to play oblivion.
It's... I don't know why.
I saw like the inventory menu and I was like, whoa.
Change the location that fits your playstyle.
Plus, I think I had to uninstall it.
I had no...
I had no Rubo by computer.
It's like 100 gigs.
When taking on massive monsters, you can climb them to
strike their weak points.
Fighting alongside your pawns is key to victory.
Oh my god, he's just climbing that Yeti.
In a world between dark and light, embark on an adventure
and tell a tale all your own.
What fate awaits the arisen and their pawns?
Dragons Dogma 2.
Dark Arisen launches on Nintendo Switch 2, October 9th.
Otherworldly endeavors await in these games.
Otherworldly endeavors?
Earth has been driven to the brink of annihilation by
mysterious life forms called the Nativa.
Now, join Eve on her mission to save humanity and reclaim
the planet.
I think it's really funny that when, like, people talk about
Stellar Blade, they're like, better whatever but didn't they
have a collab they're obviously friendly with each other the
situation can you save humanity and reclaim earth for
humankind stellar blade launches on Nintendo switch 2 this
year blast off in the two-player co-op adventure orbitals
protect your home yeah something something two cakes There
are many interstellar areas to explore.
Melt ice to make a path.
This game looks...
Activate devices in time with the beat.
Like visually.
Escape from incoming enemies and more.
Brave the dangers ahead in your poignant blue the stars.
Two players can also work together locally or online using
GameShare.
Oh!
Work together and overcome the crisis of the cosmos.
Crisis of the cosmos.
Launches exclusively on the Nintendo Switch 2 system,
September 3rd.
Only Switch 2.
Pre-orders begin later today on Nintendo eShop.
Oh, there's Rayman again.
Reimagining of Rayman Legends.
When a shadowy villain starts spreading corruption.
It's up to Rayman and his friends to leave.
It's... Rhythm Heaven is saving us.
Everything is September and October!
musical stages and enjoy more added content.
Up to four players can go out on a limb in local co-op.
You can also play a revamped version of Kung Fu using
GameShare locally or online.
Mirror isn't better than Stelibleth?
Uh-oh, there's a fight more to some people.
Nintendo Switch 2 October 1st.
GTA 6 Panic.
It's a great day for a big wall.
Oh wait!
Get lost!
This is finally coming out!
co-op walking and talking adventure set off through a
peaceful world brimming with challenges puzzles and lots of
things to discover it's so pretty it's so funny to look
together to find your way around use all sorts of tools to
stay in touch and figure out new methods of communicating if
you're in a pickle.
Oh!
Thank you.
They might even be a little unconventional.
Ah.
And if you're not quite up to adventuring, you can always
just relax with your pals.
Oh, I'm gonna relax with my pals.
Oh, and dance with my pals.
Or steal something from a friend and kick it into the ocean.
Why would you do that?
Why is that an ability?
You can also use mouse controls or hang out with friends
using cross-platform play.
After all, spending quality time together is the best part
of a...
Big walk.
You're in celebrate, don't need to fight.
We have two cakes.
Yeah, exactly.
We don't need to fight.
Season the seeds.
They can exist together.
Oh, that looks...
Oh, I'm getting...
Sanji?
Build your very own floating restaurant with the Straw Hat
crew.
That looks amazing.
I'm going to get fried rice to this.
Cook up recipes with Sanji.
Sanji?
Sanji.
Oh.
No, I can't look at this right now.
I'm too hungry.
By searching for and collecting ingredients, you'll expand
your menu offerings.
Wait, skeleton time.
I just saw that.
Good luck.
fruit abilities to prepare piping hot steaks or whip up
tongue-tingling ta-ta noodles you can make all sorts of
delicious dishes spend in-game money to change up the
restaurant's interior and expand it to attract even more
customers over 400 characters from the one piece series oh
my god i mean there are like 400 characters in one piece but
This is extensive!
Holy cow!
Grand Gourmet.
Sailing onto the Nintendo Switch 2 and Nintendo Switch
Systems October 25th.
We're over 800, I believe that even, too.
Oh, I told you, Pokopia!
Something, something.
Underwater?
How did she know?
Because I know all.
I'm so in tune with my gamer instincts.
Even beneath the sea.
Explore the world on the ocean floor with a free update.
By using the new move dive, you can enjoy life with Pokemon
living under the sea.
So cute!
Build structures.
The bushes.
Wait a second.
This is so...
This free update is scheduled to release in August 2026.
It's a little bear looking, but...
You can't just put bushes under the water.
Oh, that looks great.
The expansion pass paid DLC is on the way.
Discover a brand new town, Bubbly Basin.
There you'll find new furniture.
New outfits.
Bubbly Basin.
And new friends.
Bubbly O's!
The Pokemon Pokopia expansion pass paid DLC.
DLC will be available later today on Nintendo eShop.
So there's a free expansion that allows you to go onto the
water and then the paid one.
Bubbley Basin launches this August.
Part two and part three will launch at a later date.
Look out for more details in the future.
Hello.
Ooh.
What's for breakfast, Minto?
Veggie chips.
Thank you for the super chat.
We hope you're looking forward to more content for Pokemon
Pocopia via a free update and paid DLC.
Next, please take a look at this.
What was that?
This is the Dagdan Empire, a prosperous land ruled by the
gods.
The capital, Daxian, plays host to the heroic games.
The winner of which is granted one wish.
Powerful fighters from across the land have gathered to
participate.
Wow, Randy.
Yep.
The story revolves around four heroes.
Kai, a young boy determined to win the games to save his
imprisoned father.
Dietrich, a swordsman ever on the hunt for a stronger foe.
Dora, a queen seeking to fulfill the long-held dream of her
homeland.
And Lita, a musician with her sights set on revenge.
Guide whichever character you choose to victory as they
weave their own unique tale.
Between matches, you can strengthen your forces in different
ways.
Fire Emblem, Vania.
Hone your techniques at the training grounds.
Thank you so much for the...
Phil, thank you so much for the...
Recruit new allies.
Or travel beyond Daxian's walls to gain experience.
How you spend your free time is up to you.
Combat takes the form of turn-based tactical battles.
Consider your weapons range.
I never was able to get in the fire emblem.
It's just not my type of gameplay.
Which...
Makes me sad because...
This is such like a legacy series.
By using these techniques to the fullest, you might turn the
tide of battle.
Maybe one day I'll like watch somebody's playthrough or
something.
Rejoice with me!
Permadeath is hard to get into.
At the advent of the underworld.
I think games like this sometimes require you to be pretty
sweaty, but I don't...
I'm just too casual of a game.
And guide the living to salvation.
Kiara will play this.
You think so?
To upheave the world.
There is casual mode, that's true.
Be gone from us.
The darkest dark.
Low difficulties?
It's actually pretty easy, yeah.
The Fire Emblem, Fortune's Weave, launches September 17th.
Alongside the standard edition, there will be a special
edition, the Fire Emblem, Fortune's Weave Dagnon Collection,
that launches the same day.
Please look forward to it.
Let's continue with some more headlines.
Thank you so much for the thank you, third!
Everything is September!
I'm going insane!
I'm actually going insane!
How was everything September, October?
Like, it's... I...
I...
You guys can tell me GTA a million times, but it's
actually...
The first part of Ninja Latu is sneaking on to Nintendo
Switch 2.
Ninja Latu!
After accidentally breaking a forbidden seal, they're
stranded on an uncharted planet.
Overcome the dangers lurking here to safely return to Earth
in this open world.
Ninja Turtles.
Action adventure.
Use Ninja Gum to freely traverse this vast world.
in search of clues to get back home ninja gum you can also
blow a bubble to float in the air defeat enemies blocking
your path with weapons crafted from ninja gum you remember
the 24th of september every game and exist this is your
release you better watch the first part of ninja money
everyone scared of dj to barbie which is exclusively on the
nintendo switch 2 system next spring spring the dk challenge
barrels in dk challenge coming to nintendo switch online on
nintendo switch 2 the limited time dk challenge event take
on challenges across many donkey con games available with
nintendo classics
can earn and enjoy collectible digital challenge cards and
if you have Donkey Kong bonanza you can attempt even more
challenges yay I love digital cards or take on developer
challenges for something with a bit more punch rediscovered
Donkey Kong has properties about ninja and go collection DK
challenge can be access via the Nintendo Switch online app
on the home menu of your Nintendo Switch 2.
You'll be able to feral through these limited time
challenges starting later today.
Oh, wow, okay.
That's a lot of time, though.
Plus, in the Donkey Kong Bonanza, DK Island and Emerald Rush
paid DLC, a limited time collaboration with Super Mario
Brothers is breaking through.
Enjoy outfits for DK and Pauline.
Oh wait, wait, Luigi Pauli at his peak!
Wait, I'm afraid it might be the best thing I've ever seen!
Wait!
Experience Emerald Rush as you've never seen before with a
Super Mario Bros.
twist!
Wait!
This limited time collaboration event will be held in four
waves with a first wave beginning later today.
I think I need...
Oh!
Is this the...
crawlers the vampire crawlers one no wait the latest game in
the makers of vampire survivors jujutsu kaisen rumble
survive the time jujutsu kaisen so much to up to eight
players can compete online oh my gosh barrel bug someone
check on her at the start of the match players don't battle
directly instead take down enemies on your own map to earn
points Each time you earn 100 points, you can add a rule to
your run.
Ju-Jutsu survivors.
The match culminates in a head-to-head final battle between
the top two players.
Who will be the final survivor?
More than 20 characters from the Ju-Jutsu Kaizen series
appear.
Characters can be unlocked just by playing.
Battle online with players near and far.
Wait, so it's like a battle royale?
Kind of?
It's a battle royale.
The Survivor's Game?
And rise to the top.
Jujutsu Kaisen Rumble's Survivaton launches on Nintendo
Switch 2 this year.
Aww.
Interesting.
Are you up for the challenge in these games?
Stand proud when you are free.
Drupal unforgiving battle storm onto Nintendo Switch 2.
In the forsaken world, a looming darkness devours all in its
path.
Now, only one kingdom endures.
You want to get stuff in time for a moment?
holiday shopping season.
I feel like October makes sense for holiday shopping.
I don't know.
Am I just waiting until the last minute of November?
My brain isn't thinking about the holidays around that time.
Maybe I'm abnormal though.
Lords of the Fallen 2 launches on Nintendo Switch 2.
1000% because of GTA.
GTA can't be the only thing that releases at the end of the
year though.
Oh, is this a...
That...
Based on the story of Pinocchio in Rise of P. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
In a city under siege, you must fight rampaging mechanical
puppets and seek the cause of this upheaval while
confronting your own humanity.
Take on enemies using customizable weapons and prosthetic
arms that allow you to swap between different abilities.
The lies you tell will alter your fate.
Oh my god.
He won't ever stop lying.
Never.
Complete Edition, which includes overture.
Why isn't his nose a thousand feet long?
Launches on the Nintendo Switch 2 system August 6th.
Pre-orders begin later today.
I wanted to play it.
I don't know.
I've heard it's difficult, though.
The most recent entry in the legendary Devil May Cry series
is slashing its way to Nintendo Switch 2.
There is Mira.
Dante, V, and Virgil with each arm with different battle
styles as you fight off boards of demons and epic bosses.
Pull off stylish attacks, dodges and combos with your vast
arsenal of weapons and skills.
Enjoy thrilling high octane combat at 60 frames per second.
Smoking sexy style.
Plus additional content such as battle traps, character
colors and devil breaker weapons for Nero.
are included devil may cry 5 devil hunter edition launches
on nintendo switch 2 june 23rd pre-orders begin later today
now i'm motivated oh no marvelous wait i fear i must buy it
wait it's all oh my gosh so you're looking for some runaway
ninja named kisuke they still have some unfinished business
i fear i must buy it because Because...
If people don't buy it, then they think people won't want
DMC-6.
I don't know.
I'd start repenting if I were you.
An action RPG for the ages.
What fate awaits those who wield the Demon Blades?
Yeah, Muramasa!
Muramasa, Revenant Blades.
Oh!
All 15 Xenoblade fans rejoice.
All three games run at 60 frames per second.
You have been heard.
With 4K resolution and TV mode or full HD in handheld mode.
Actually, I think that joke is like, it's so funny, but
also, I think nowadays...
She's not blurry!
Nowadays, I think because of new Xenoblade...
But you can travel on a high-speed vehicle in the first
game.
There are dozens of us.
Yeah.
Control blades to fight mercenary squad battles in the
second.
And put your strength to the test against waves of enemies
in the third.
There's also a variety of other content added to each of the
three games.
More details will be revealed at a later date.
Mithra.
digital version of Xenoblade Chronicles Definitive Edition,
Nintendo Switch 2 Edition.
Rogue Light mode.
It'll be available later today.
Later today!
The physical version launches on July 30th.
The Nintendo Switch 2 editions of Xenoblade Chronicles 2 and
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 will be available on the dates shown
on screen.
What if they showed that they got even more accents?
Three Xenoblade Chronicles games are getting Nintendo Switch
2 editions.
Whoa!
New features will be added to each title, so we hope you'll
check them out.
And a new story in the Xenoblade series is about to begin.
Here are some early moments from the game.
Guys?
Wait.
He looks exactly like that one needs to change his remarks.
This is very cute though.
I like her design very much.
Like, oh, everybody's got a big old pointy ears.
Except this guy.
Get out of your round ears.
Pointy ears all around.
Yeah,
I like her massive ears too.
Bigger, bigger.
Oh, yes!
Say that soon.
All that's all.
Bigger!
You're going to go to that place.
Yeah!
Oh,
she's so cute.
Oh, she's so cute.
This is so cute.
Whoa!
Zenoblade?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Genesis?
Ah!
Zenoblade Genesis marks a new beginning.
Oh my gosh!
What kind of story do you think will be told?
Please look forward to future updates.
Oh my gosh!
Next.
Oh.
Please take a look at this.
Oh no.
Mario Tennis.
Welcome to Woohoo Island.
Welcome to all kinds of sports.
Coming to Nintendo Switch 2.
Nintendo Switch Sports Resort.
Every Sims fan just blushed, I think.
Oh, it's Wii Sports.
We're going to Woohoo Island, everybody.
Or even Handles.
There are 12 sports to choose from.
12 sports.
All with intuitive motion controls.
Let's go over them.
We sports.
No.
Punch, guard, counter, and out maneuver for the knockout in
boxing.
Oh, dang.
Yeah, uppercut.
Yeah, get her.
To keep your opponent on their toes.
In table tennis.
Table tennis.
Aim for the center of the target and let that arrow fly.
In archery.
Nice.
Enjoy rallies.
with different types of shots in tennis bump bump set and
spike in bally ball wonder what goes on there roll the ball
straight it's a mystery though obviously big in bowling
dribble pass and shoot to score in basketball adjust your
shots power then swing your hand golf in golf
wrestling!
Guys, I'm a pro at this actually.
Wait, that's kind of awesome!
I'm not a pro!
Also, I think it's very funny that this is all like sports,
but like...
Steer with handles and coast along the way.
But skateboarding is just like rolling your...
Delta controller and fly around freely.
Just rolling your Joy-Con.
I'm a pro at...
You can warm up for these sports with jump rope.
You can create a...
and play as a sportsmate.
Or Mika.
I think if there were an anime about it, I would be the
protagonist.
Oh.
One of these Mies is not like the other.
They're like, do you think they're mean to him?
They're like, oh, he's from like the old.
Enjoy playing all kinds of sports on Nintendo Switch 2.
Nintendo Switch Sports Resort launches exclusively on the
Nintendo Switch 2 system October 22nd.
These are back, baby!
Nintendo eShop.
Nintendo Switch Sports Resort is coming to Nintendo Switch
2.
We showed all the sports included, but since we have the
opportunity, let's try one of the new sports, Thumb
Wrestling.
Yeah, I was gonna say, try Thumb Wrestling, please.
Before the match, let's go over the rules.
Hold down your opponent's thumb for three seconds, and
you'll win.
If yours gets pinned, just shake the control.
Roller to break free.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Just rip my shirt and lost my voice during Xeno Play
section.
Happy for you, Sabertude.
Three, two, one.
You'll need this to clean the kitchen.
Holy...
Here's to a great thumb wrestling match.
Why are their hands like that?
Wait a second, why are their...
Wait, actually, why are their hands like that?
What?
Here we go.
Let's have a good match.
Whoa, wait.
Oh, got him right away.
The yowie hands are crazy.
Let's try this.
Oh, we bumped thumbs.
Oh, oh, keep a pin.
Yeah.
Oh, no, they broke out.
You have to keep them pinned.
Hey, why'd you put your thumb down, man?
I was worried for a second there.
okay I'm started to sparkle and the male got bigger yeah
that's not how it's supposed to go it's okay everything is
fine my thumb returned to normal maybe they should have
shown him playing the game oh I got deflected ah wait wait a
minute I lost.
Please wait a little longer for Nintendo Switch Sports
Resort.
Let's move on to more headlines.
Let's keep going.
I can't believe we lost an NPC.
Oh, RuneScape again.
on the forgotten continent it's like three times that we've
seen this game this week explore a land infused with magic
they're like really there they are going all in on runescape
advertising in this survival crafting adventure delve into
the mysteries of ashen fall amongst the ruins of fallen
civilizations on your expedition harness the land's
transformative magic
Crap gear Control fan to the next trailer I need to cry
He'll get him next time He was He lost So that when
everybody wins They feel like Oh yeah I'm so good at game
You know It was to make everybody else It was to boost
everybody's Eagle Because they're just like Wow he lost
There's no way I could win But then you win And then you're
like Yeah I'm the greatest to never do it!
Get on board for these games.
Hello Kitty Island.
Hanamaru, please add!
Hanamaru Obake.
Hanamaru Obake, if you are there, please make a sound.
There are over 120 Sanrio characters to meet.
Make a sound, please!
Hanamaru Obake, if you're there, please make a sound!
Sound!
Good.
And so much more.
Hello Kitty Party Land launches exclusively on Nintendo
Switch 2 and Nintendo Switch October 29th.
So let's get down there and finish the job.
Blast off for adventure across the Lilat system with Fox
McLeod and his crew.
Well done, Fox!
A battle for the fate of the galaxy begins.
Star Fox launches on Nintendo Switch 2 June 25th.
Okay, I'm not mad about Star Fox.
A free demo that includes a tutorial and one of the game's
opening stages will be available later today on Nintendo
eShop.
Is it only Switch 2?
Oh, it looks good, dog.
Get ready for the first Final Fantasy game in Asia.
HD 2D, Final Fantasy Resonance.
Oh, what?
This is Lapis, a vast world that has prospered through the
power of crystals.
But after the invasion of the Veritas, this once-thriving
world lies on the brink of annihilation.
Now, Rain, a knight of Grandshelves must journey across the
realm of his companions to stop the Veritas.
thrilling turn-based battles call upon visions the kind
final fantasy heroes from other worlds to take down monsters
can you uncover the truth behind the veritas and the secrets
the crystals hold final fantasy resonance launches on
nintendo switch 2 and nintendo switch systems october 22nd
oh my gosh A weird, whimsical world is waiting.
Oh, that cup is something.
Pikuniku returns in a new 3D puzzle exploration adventure.
What do giant fruit, malevolent robot frogs, and an
all-powerful potato have in common?
Nothing.
Other than a shadowy conspiracy, of course.
Meet a cavalcade of curious characters.
Each with their own problems and puzzles to solve.
happy world actually 3d man jump scare time to join the
resistance by using piku's surprising abilities help solve
the people's problems in surprising and downright oddball
ways feeling baffled by these affable denizens embrace these
strange encounters and bring about an ultimate understanding
and in this see right now navigate and explore in full 3d as
you discover the secrets of this vivid, colorful world.
Wow!
Get ready to wander, solve, and gossip in...
Pikuniku 2.
What's the key?
Launching on Nintendo Switch 2 next year.
Feels like this should be a horror game, actually, though.
Prepare for...
Oh!
And all new...
Monster-filled adventure!
Yeah?
Look at all of them!
Look at all these monsters!
Two girls find themselves left in the Kingdom of Witherwood.
There they gain the power to turn monsters into friends.
Hey.
Spot a monster you fancy.
Scout it.
Win it over and it'll fight by your side.
Oh no.
That's not all.
synthesize two monsters to create more powerful allies now
take on the most fearsome of foes with a team that's
uniquely your own is this allowed adventure is calling and
it's monstrously fun dragon quest monsters the wizard world
you got here every dragon quest fan is screaming about about
her right now
it's so cute i think i i have to get it wait isn't this the
is this the game that everybody's been was yelling about in
my chat
we are monsters each for blood
worthy spirit
oh oh our
m6 is here this summer next we have more news guys we are
absolutely getting spoiled this this this past week actually
hey Hey everyone, here are some fresh news about Splatoon
Raiders, a new single-player focused adventure.
Check out this neat little place, the Hideout Ship out on
the water.
There's Deep Cut, a trio of swashbuckling musicians.
And this scrappy individual, that's you.
Let's call this handy youth the mechanic.
The four of them are using the Hideout Ship as their hub,
while hunting for treasure across these landmasses, the
Spiralite Islands.
all right time for a quick dive looks like the treasure
thereafter is at the base of those lights but there's a
bunch of aggressive creatures called salmonids in the way
and when you get too close they'll attack immediately the
salmonids aren't pushovers either so you shouldn't go it
alone that's where this comes in was platoon 2 a member of
deep cut pilots it during your treasure hunt my roommate
would automatically launches you in this mode and there was
like a song that like to unleash special moves like
absolutely like there was like a certain instrument in it
that would make me cringe like i got actual shivers oh yeah
salmon rod yeah yeah oh it just drove me absolutely insane
So seeing them, I'm like, I'm getting nauseous.
I'm getting nauseous thinking about it.
It wasn't that I heard it so many times.
It was just a certain instrument that they used in their
theme that was like, or like in the mode.
I don't know if it was part of the music or part of the
environment, but I was like, oh my God, please.
will also get stronger by letting it end and you can
customize all sorts of upgrades to fit your play style oh
looks like time's up there are even more details to cover in
the upcoming splatoon raiders direct airing on june 30th and
in the smart device app nintendo today see the story events
leading up to splatoon raiders with daily comics ahead of
launch plus in collaboration with game there's gonna be a
special splat fest in splatoon 3 the theme looks like it's
about splatoon raiders details will be announced no way look
out for more info in the future don't forget to check this
out too whoa cute
so what did you think it looks like it's about the thing we
just talked about
by deep cut we hope you're looking forward to it let's see
some more headlines yeah more more more
no freaking way oh my god oh my god it's actually happening
oh my god
waiting June 24th oh my god oh my god oh heed me o kingless
whosoever have truly earned the greatest faith of the
citizenry I was literally just talking about this metaphor
game this is the united kingdom of Eukronia the phantazio
the next king shall be decided by the will of the people by
decree of the king as his face floats in the sky the
tournament for the throne begins as the realm he's really
looking his face floats in the sky as one of the throne's
candidates you'll travel across the kingdom forging bonds
with compelling characters along the way when you when you
point six your camera and then put it really funny on your
face monsters roaming this world as well as other candidates
and strange beasts known as humans control your destiny and
change the world in metaphor re-fantazio re-fantazio
launching on the Nintendo Switch 2 system November 12th
explore survive love this game a dedicated Nintendo Switch 2
version of Minecraft on the way.
Yeah.
Dig into your Minecraft adventure on Nintendo Switch 2 with
support for vibrant visuals.
Oh!
And embark on a journey across a world with enhanced
lighting and shadow effects.
Oh my god.
Plus, Nintendo Switch worlds can be carried over so you can
pick up right where you left off.
Wow!
What will you create next?
Minecraft.
I love this game, guys.
I love this game.
I love his game.
I saw an old man!
Give me more of him!
Give me more!
Give me an amiibo!
So little concern he's put in this like montage sequence.
That looks very good.
Daisy!
Please!
Metal Gear, Metal Gear!
Oh, I got to see him today.
My stuff is packed so I don't get to look at him all the
time anymore.
Furry Minecraft.
Whoa.
No Miku.
No Miku Boxing.
The Battle of Light and Darkness approaches.
Filled with memorable adventures.
Three collections of Kingdom Hearts games are coming to
Nintendo Switch 2.
Traverse through iconic Disney and Pixar worlds.
There has to be...
Befriend all sorts of magical allies.
There has to be a record.
And battle enemies in action RPG combat.
But how many times a game can be re-released?
This is like...
I swear Kingdom Hearts has the record.
If you have the cloud versions on Nintendo Switch, you can
transfer your existing save data to these Nintendo Switch 2
games.
We're gonna get the baby another one soon.
These are collections launched on Nintendo Switch 2 October
8th.
R.E.4.
Okay.
Skyrim.
That's fair too.
It's up there though.
It's up there.
I feel like...
Additionally, a free demo of Kingdom Hearts 3 plus Remind
will be available later today on Nintendo eShop.
Oh!
It's Skyrim and Doom 2.
Okay, okay, I'm saying it's up there.
Wait.
Guys.
Guys?
This is...
Oh my god!
We got out!
That's why I said there's hope!
They wouldn't have...
I said there was hope!
Oh my god.
This...
What does that mean?
Wait, what does...
What do you mean at launch?
Next is our last announcement.
When is the launch?
That wasn't the last announcement.
Long ago.
There was a land called
Harry Edge of this kingdom.
Within it, an ancient solitary tree quietly watched over the
inhabitants of the family.
Oh my god.
These forest dwellers were called the Kokiri.
Each had a fairy companion, and they lived out their
innocent lives in these woods.
However, there was one particular boy who did not have a
voice.
a fairy.
What?
This year?
They couldn't say a date because of GTA 6.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
So please look forward to them.
that's all for today's Nintendo Direct oh my god earlier
this year Devonson was appointed as the new president of
Nintendo of America to conclude this presentation with a few
words from Devonson thank you for watching thank you Koizumi
Sun hi everyone I'm Devon Pritchard and after 20 years at
Nintendo one of my favorite things about gaming is still
that moment I get to try something new.
I watch the trailers, I hear about a game, but the moment I
pick up a controller, that's when it all comes together.
And for me, that's what games have always been about, those
little moments that surprise me and allow me to immerse
myself in different worlds.
You can read about a game, you can watch a trailer, but
nothing beats seeing it for yourself.
And that's a big part of what Nintendo Treehouse Live is
about.
Getting a closer look, hearing from the games themselves so
let's get to it we've got a new nintendo treehouse live oh
yeah the treehouse with a few games you guys want to watch
it or and if you enjoyed splatoon raiders in today's
nintendo direct this july at san diego comic-con will have
the game playable on the show floor because at the end of
the day how long is it going to be i think the best way to
understand the game is to pick up the controller and play
thanks for watching i'm really looking forward to sharing
more of what I love about games.
I'll leave it up.
I'll just turn it down a little bit.
We can chat.
And now it's time for Treehouse Live.
Over to you, team.
What has happened this past week?
What?
90 minutes.
Holy cow.
What has happened?
This...
Oh.
Hi, everyone.
Hi.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm joined here by Gab, Dan, and Rob.
It's been...
It's been insane.
It's coming out June 25th.
It is a new F-Zero game.
I'm just dumb.
I'm sorry.
Kingdom Hearts.
Check out the new cinema scene right here in this new cinema
scene right on the Star Oh yeah, we could do that.
We could do that.
No free PS.
I get for the pink.
There's something there you might be interested in.
Oh.
Yeah?
We can do that real quick.
Hold on.
I gotta go find it.
Uh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh.
Um, how many games are you going to keep manifesting?
I didn't think it would be a, I didn't think it would be a,
a remake.
Uh, wait, is there a timestamp I should go to or anything?
the one for japan is over
i didn't expect a remake
holy hell that was crazy though that was actually crazy i
can't believe they i can't believe that he announced the
kingdom hearts in the nintendo direct
I'm not sure what to look for in the Japanese one I'm like
kind of scrolling through it but
was there much different?
I mean I know that usually there is but it looks like this
to me is pretty similar
I can't believe Kingdom Hearts wasn't the last announcement
right
I'm laughing so hard Nintendo was the one to break the
kingdom hearts for that's what i'm saying the fact that
108.35 oh wait hold on here we go seller blade edio
Oh my god.
Here they have!
Oh yeah.
This winter!
Oh my god?
Oh my god!
Miko's Reim and the spellmaker by the way she manages to
eradicate the game.
Oh, baby!
Oh!
Oh, oh!
What?
A time.
Gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even think...
I think of...
I think of like a decade ago.
Ten years ago.
I could never imagine Toho on a Switch.
Toho on a Nintendo proper...
Oh my gosh.
God!
Holy cow!
Wait, let's see him.
He's in here.
They snuck him in here.
Where are you?
Wait, what is this?
It looked like this guy...
Cute.
Yeah, we got that.
Tamagotchi.
Where'd he go?
I can't remember.
I thought he was part of the...
Tell him the war.
I thought he was part of the fitness boxing.
I don't see him, though.
They don't want to show...
They don't want to show Snake in the JP one.
This is so...
The fake-out was so crazy.
They're like, yeah, we're porting it.
Wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink.
Wink, wink, wink, wink.
Wow.
The three-titles of the Kingdom Hearts 3.
...
Only embrace combat died.
Nah, and don't be great.
Wait.
He looks like V.
Is that Zigbar?
Everybody looks too fancy.
I can't tell who they are.
Sora's face.
Look at him.
Who is that?
Or Luxor, that's what I meant.
Not Zigbar, sorry.
Luxor, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody looks too fancy.
They look too different.
Sora looks like a...
Sora looks like a totally different person.
Look at the umbrella.
It's all broken.
Did
that was Riku, everybody, every, every Riku Joshi's heart
is, is like, yeah, his shoes are no longer humongous.
He still runs the same at least, but.
Kingdom Hearts 4.
This is so funny.
Like I get what it means that there will be, when the game
is, is, is, is, it comes out it will also be available on
nintendo switch too but the fact that it just says at launch
with no date is so funny it's so funny speaking of directs
if you're flying directly to new york this august you may be
nintendo interested if this is anything in skyline serenade
a live show starring Minto and three other amazing
headliners.
Yeah!
Why didn't you say that they could go to the Nintendo Store
in New York?
If you want to go to Nintendo Store in New York, you could
also hit up Skyline Serendade in August.
You could go to the Nintendo Store in New York.
It was all a fire, that guy.
Wow guys we have been absolutely fed I fear I fear that
there are
oh sorry I just saw your message oh yeah you pinned it okay
not only did you manifest Kingdom Hearts 4 in the Aquary of
Time Vitamin of Scarlet Devil Remake.
I kneel to my Oshi.
I can't...
That is...
Toho Remake.
Crazy.
Since they announced Minecraft, can you stream it, please?
I would love to stream Minecraft.
No wonder you guys beat above me.
Holy cow.
Toho is wild.
Any Manifestive Bloodborne 3?
I did say.
I did say, but I didn't know what power I held.
I put on my list.
Oh, well, I did put Ace Attorney.
There was no Ace Attorney, sadly.
But I wrote Zelda and Ace Attorney.
I feel like I need to start making bingo cards for real.
The Year of Threes.
I want to take a nap after that.
Wow.
Well, guys, I hope you enjoyed the direct.
Wait.
I saw her.
My wife.
Get out of your Prince of Tennis.
I actually haven't seen any...
Oh, there it is.
There it goes.
I haven't seen any like...
footage of it.
They've...
They've VTuberified them.
Steins Gate!
Steins Gate reboot?
Never heard of it.
Okay, get out of here, man.
Oh, gosh.
They move, I know!
I want to see...
She's so beautiful.
They made a game for Steiner.
The guy is so famous, they made a game based off of him.
Disgusting.
Is that why his name is Steiner?
I look at her and I see Kiara.
would include lord lord lord lord lord lord couldn't they
make pick an easier name to say lord lord lord lord lord
lord lord
it's up about lisa p it makes you get good at pairing and
it's not optional you might want to check that's why that's
why i that's why I said that's, I haven't played it yet.
What a great direct.
Exciting.
That was so fun.
I hope you guys had fun too.
Sorry that maybe I was a little low energy.
It's just so early in the morning.
But I'm going to go get breakfast.
What do you, wait.
What should I have for breakfast?
What should I have?
I've been trying to like eat the places that are my local
places that I can't have anymore so I'm like maybe I just do
lunch instead I don't know Sanji's fried rice looks really
good oatmeal time to go to caesarea if only pancakes
three apples I would like more than that unless apples and
peanut butter it's that's peak pancakes or waffles i could
go four apples that's that's too much too much too much
that's like literally the size of hello kitty actually how
many apples tall is hello kitty how many apples tall is
hello Kitty.
She is five apples tall.
She's five apples tall.
French toast.
You guys have the good suggestions.
You guys have good suggestions.
I hope you guys get something good to eat too.
Five apples.
I would be eating almost as tall as that looks.
kitty big stretch oh i might go take a nap and then keep
pack pack packing mystical phil thank you so much for the
thank you thank you thank you have a yummy breakfast you
guys as well you guys as well and um hopefully i will see
you at uh at the Blue Archive Club tonight.
Don't forget Skyline Serenade tickets are now on sale.
And I'll see you guys later.
Thank you.
See you guys later.
Thank you, Minto.
Sorry, it's shorter stream.
But yeah, good luck tonight.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll go with RC later.
Take care, Minky.
You too.
Ultimateo, everybody.
Interashai.
Bye-bye.
Thank you so much.
I'm glad that we could...
I was wondering...
I was like, I don't have much time to stream.
But I want to stream.
I didn't want to just do the collab today and tomorrow.
So I'm glad we had time to hang out a little bit.
Sorry that right now is so crazy for me.
With...
with my move but um i'll get i'll get everything done as
soon as possible so that we can get back on normal schedule
i'll probably i'll write up like a mock schedule of this
week it's not much unfortunately it's i can't say that i
have too many streams it's really just tomorrow and maybe
thursday depending but i also want to spend a lot of time uh
with my cats before I can't see them anymore so um if I
stream on Thursday it will be also like probably a short
chatting stream or something like that um so yeah yeah yeah
okay thank you everybody yeah so many bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye say you bye bye bye bye